bonjour à tous alors nouvelle vidéo pour
parler de lionel kayser ce qu'ils
héritent ski pardon qui en fait est né
dans l' empire russe et qui a ensuite
déménagé en france à à paris et qui
était donc considéré que major français
eh ben on va parler de lui aussi parce
qu'à un moment il était considéré comme
le meilleur joueur du monde mais vrai
dire moi je le connaissais surtout pas
de parti ou s'est retrouvé du mauvais
côté partie éminemment célèbre contre
adolf andersen partie qu'on appelait
l'immortel donc j'imagine nous devez
connaître mais bon ça fera pas de la
revoir et les jolies il ya un match
sympa et donc je propose delà de la
regarder
et puis je ferai une autre vidéo pour
rendre hommage donc acquis et gérer ce
qui quand il sera du bon côté du bon
côté de la balance on va dire sera la
prochaine vidéo donc cette partie contre
contre anderson jouer en 1851 un match à
londres
d'ailleurs dans le match s'équilibre ce
qui l'a emporté à vrai dire mais voilà
donc celle là c'était c'est parti donc
le 4e 5 et f4 granby roi donc ouais à
l'époque c'était assez classique de la
part des blancs d'entamer par un grand
miroir et d'ailleurs il ya eu de très
bons joueurs dans l'histoire qui on joue
le grand miroir
par exemple ce parce qu'ils bronstein
même plus récemment morose et beach il a
joué de temps en temps avec de bons
résultats
donc c'est un grand miroir accepté puis
on prend un f4 donc ok c'est une basse
le bon coup en fait en général les noirs
prennent l'option est fou c'est 4 avec
les blancs donc c'est la rente avec tous
ces quatre faut noter qu'ici le couple
beaucoup l'art en général c'est qu'il y
avait les f3 pour justement contrôler la
case h4 éviter que la dame qui viennent
et essayer tous unis par des quatre
éventuellement ensuite et si les blancs
peuvent regagner ce pion f4 une fois
qu'ils ont joué des 4 et évidemment ça
sera très bien pour eux mais en général
les noirs ici le grand coup c'est de
juger 5h 4g 4 et c'est bon ça c'est une
des possibilités c'est très compliqué
mais bon dans la théorie moderne ça va
pour les noirs quoi toujours est il fou
ces 4es avec les noirs et la juda mach 4
échecs donc il veut dire ok le roi blanc
peut-être que le plus simple pour ceux
d'entre vous qui je veux 4,5 si vous
avez cette position c'est de jouer
pendant qu'edf 6 avec l'intention que je
vide des 5 et
à ce moment là pour vite finir le
développement quoi par michael c3
défendent pions et on pourrait faire ses
6 suivis par des 5 voilà une manière de
jouer
on rentre pas dans temps du damage cas
des positions trop sauvage mais on joue
normalement pour pour développer
contrôler le centre bon toujours est
t'il damage quatre échecs au roi f1 donc
les blancs perdre le droit de rockets
mais ils vont bien sûr regagner un temps
sur la dame avec bf3 essayer de faire
des 4 et puis peut-être plus tard faire
un roi f2 là tout rentrera en jeu en f1
ou en lin on verra et et voilà alors qui
est ce qui joue son fournil et c'est de
jouer et b5
bon je crois que c'est pas terrible en
fait objectivement l'idée c'est quoi
c'est juste vous deviez le fou et voilà
bas moins il est plus à regarder f7 il
est moins bien placé peut-être on
gagnera un temps dessus
et pourquoi pas développer le fossé huit
ans baissaient tous quelque part comme
ça cavalli et six attaques le piano
quatre bons qu'ils avaient les f3
attaque la dame damage 6 et dans la
partie il a joué des trois peut-être un
peu timoré bon en même temps ça défend
le 4 et ça permet aux phocéens de
s'activer
mais un coup comme cali c3 ici sera
sûrement très bien avec l'intention soit
joué donc d4 soi même peut-être faire
2,5 et chasser ce cavalier
d'ailleurs il ya une partie jouer
là-dessus bon c'est en blitz
c'était début imposé en fait c'était
avant le le match de championnat du
monde 93 entre kasparov et chartes donc
qui était à londres également mises
avait fait un match de blitz et on leur
a imposé un peu d'ouverture et kasparov
avait eu les noirs dans cette partie et
il est perdu très rapidement je peux
vous montrer
il est fait j'ai cinq ici donc voici et
de solidifier un peu les pions tout ça
mais des quatre joué par les blancs très
logique
phobies 7 et h4 bien jouer h4 menace
cavalli pranger cinq tours g8 donc sa
défense
c'est quand même un clouage si cai
pranger cinq tours prend les blancs ne
peuvent pas reprendre simplement parce
qu'il ya la tourache 1 qui
qui sera en l'air donc serré pas du tout
pour les blancs donc tourgéville défend
mayroy g1 défend la tour donc créé la
menace h pranger 5 il a pris ici tout
reprend donc quelque part ça développe
la tour d'alger 6 mai à samatan j'ai
deux dames eux deux et déjà on n'a pas
envie de râler noirs ici parce qu'on est
mal développé fou prend 1,81 arriver
éventuellement eu cinq cavaliers aux
cinq vins plein de coups possible vers
l'avant faut prendre 6 4 comme on l'a
dit bon il a pris le pion mais le
problème en fait c'est que ce cavalli
cloué sont pas très bon pour pour les
noirs f5 défend cavaliers h4 attaque
adam d'alger 3 accueille pendant quatre
abandons
pourquoi parce que scipion prend tout
reprend et chaque disons fou prend dame
prend 3 bougez bon les bonnes qualités
de moi n'en voit que la torah 8 est mal
en point
élisons qui avaient des f-5 attaque adam
g iii qui va bouger en trois huit mais
on se retrouve avec une pièce de plus et
voilà donc c'était juste une partie plus
modernes sur cette variante et ouais ça
se passe bien pour les blancs général
quoi bon alors d'un autre parti ce qui
nous intéresse il ya eu des trois
cavaliers h5 bon pas terrible ça rebouge
encore le cavalier bon évidemment
e-menaces la petite fourchette qui est
g3 toujours la même histoire avec la
tour qui traînent là bas mais avec les
boys de la vue et les jeux qui avait 10
h 4 alors pourquoi pas mais tout revient
sûrement meilleur donc on évite la
menace et de 2 en fait on veut jouer g4
c'est une grosse menace puisque la prise
en passant n'est pas vraiment possible
parce qu'ils aient la dame derrière et
une fois qu'on aura chassé ce qu'avait
lyon fra g5 un truc comme ça
bref alors il l'a pas fait pour rien il
a fait cavalier h4 d'alger cinq attaques
lecavalier il est venu la c6 attaque le
chou bon on aurait pu simplement le
reculer mais il a joué g4
voilà donc toujours pas de pause en
passant il a sauvé le cavalier bon
peut-être s'éprend b pas mal tour à tour
g1 défendre pions g4 et la banque ou
patates pour les noirs çà il prend la
pièce met un coup comme h5 a été plus
malin ça allait donner de l'air à la
dame en fait c'était important
on va le voir s'éprend b donc h4 attaque
la dame d'alger 6h cinq attaques l'adav
il revient à angers 5 et d'un f3 donc
d'un 9,3 coûts de développement menace
simplement fou prend un f4 et la dame g5
doit être être enfermé donc fait cai et
vite
histoire de se donner des kazakhs adams
wife 6 ou 10 8
vous prendrez quatre dames et 6 cas et
c3 est juste on se rend compte bien sur
les blancs sacrifier une pièce mais
avantage de développement colossal dire
quasiment toutes les pièces blanches où
on peut menacer un coup comme eux cinq
déjà peut-être au prochain coup le
cavalier c3 peut venir vers des saints
qui ça vienne tous les côtés c'est hyper
dangereux
il a joué fous ces cinq dans la partie
donc attaque la tour g1 et développe le
chou mais on peut regarder un petit oeil
à fougue et sa passion pour éviter caïds
et 5
bon le problème ses peintures et qu'elle
prend b5 menace qu'est et c'est cette
fourchette est même dame prend b2 qui
fait quelque part une double attaque
entre la tour 1 et le cahier bessin qui
bat ça va pas être suffisant puisqu'ils
répondent qu'ils si cet échec aura bouge
et disons roger 2 lille et tours donc
qui sont défendues
qui apprend à 8 va arriver tourbes et un
des coups comme ça et toutes les pièces
blanches attaque le renoir donc déjà là
c'était déjà pas terrible bon il a fait
ses 5es avec les blancs donc il se lance
dans dans une attaque et il fait qu'il y
ait des 5
sûrement que je tranquille comme des
quatre ont été mieux parce que on va
compter les parcs et des cinq quoi qu'il
en soit au prochain coup sans laisser
trop les noires s'activent et parme s'il
vous prend on fait qu'il ya des cinq
maintenant attaque la dame faudra quand
même défendre ce fou mais on voit pas
trop comment et qui essaie cette peut
arriver ouais ça se passe pas bien pour
les marcquois bon il a fait qu'il y ait
des 5
du coup il ya dame prend b2 et c'est là
donc il commence sa combinaison
fantastique
même si à vrai dire elle est entièrement
correct mais est juste très joli il a
fait fou des six
donc il met en place son réseau de maths
en fait la menace qu'ils comptent faire
un moment ça être guéri pranger s'attend
pour l'instant s'est défendue par la
dame mais voilà le roi devra les ans des
visites est fermée avec avec avec vous
des sept matches et l'autre problème
c'est que s'il faut prendre cavalli
prend du coup la dame va aller là-bas et
puis voilà il y aura plein de matane où
donc c'est le problème
là il a pris en juin et à vrai dire la
bonne défense était de faire dame prend
un échec est sûr de pas aller s'embêter
avec l'autre tours angers 1 mais revenir
et même s'il ya beaucoup d' attaque on a
quand même maintenant une tour une pièce
de plus on menace éventuellement dame
français 2 et il n'y avait pas assez
pour les bains n'y avait pas ça mais
dans la partie il a pris là ils jouent
un très bon coup mais logique vu que je
vous expliquais la menace il fait le 5
donc l'idée c'est quoi c'est simplement
qu'ils plus de protecteur de plongée
s'attend donc ils menacent cavalli prend
et sur wade 8 pouces et 7 matches
bon il a pris un par échec ça mange pas
de pain re de bondo tour une caisse de
moins mais bonne chance pour défendre le
m alors il ya eu cavaliers à 6
m
en fait il veut défendre
il veut défendre ses sept donc ça peut
sembler logique mais la suite est très
jolie qui a ébranlé cette quand même
trois des huit sous le case et
maintenant on peut plus mat et là on
peut pas maté l'abc elle qui évite qu'il
défend est là aussi mais en fait on va
servir de la surcharge du cavalier en
jouant d'ahmed 6
donc ils obligés de prendre du coup plus
personne ne défend le set et il faut 7 m
voilà donc cette partie a été appelé
l'immortel elle est très jolie
parce que dans la position finale les
blancs quand même une dame deux tours
une pièce demain et ouais il sert très
bien des trois pièces qui lui reste
qu'ils sont très bien coordonnées et
donc très beau match
voilà très belle partie qui restera
légendaire s'était jouée il ya déjà plus
de 150 ans et on la connaît tous soient
donc voila vous la montrer ecovisa la
prochaine que je vous montrera serait
une partie où qui est ce qui s'en
sortira mieux
voilà voilà allez à bientôt